today's topic i want to talk about this
for a while because i think
this doesn't get talked about enough i
had a girl hit me up a while back and
she was like
basically trying to link up and i'm like
i was kind of apprehensive i wasn't that
interested
and she kept pushing at one point i'm
just like hey listen i'm not feeling it
i don't want to do it
sorry she kept pushing and pushing i'm
like listen
i don't know what to tell you i'm just
not interested and she sent me a picture
of herself i deleted that [ __ ]
and i'm like listen i'm not we're not
going down that road and her response
was read at the bottom you ass [ __ ]
my ass abba i want that 30.
i want that 30 year olds [ __ ] you
old you get old
i bring this up for a very specific
reason a lot of people don't know this
but
oftentimes when you reject a woman and
they're not used to rejection
if they turn toxic very fast and i've
said this
when the lady says no to a man he's like
well [ __ ] you damn it's like i hate that
stuff i think
it's weak and lame i've always said that
but on the flip side ladies will start
to question your sexuality
or be like you get you this do that and
try to diminish you as a man and it
happens
often i've had this conversation with my
boys we're like yeah girls told me that
multiple times or like at last minute i
didn't want to
sleep with the person while they were
here in person and lots of time
people do this a lot but the reason why
it doesn't get talked about
is it's just because it's ladies
involved in the situation yo it's crazy
just in the dms
i get dm i remember there was one girl
coming dm and she comes off
straight up yeah i don't know none of
y'all mom yeah i don't know y'all yeah
first thing she said how tall are you
and i'm like how fat are you what is
that got to do with anything
i'm like you know what whatever i'm dry
and i'm blunt and i leave it alone
because i don't use
the love and emojis and all that i don't
do that all right
i don't do that it's yes no sure
okay or no response so i'm dry as hell
with that lady she let it let it go
she come she comes back a couple of
weeks after oh okay
i saw that first video that she put out
and i see where you said that okay cool
it's like well you super dry and then
girl i don't owe you anything i don't
know you
well i thought you were really
attractive and this and that and i don't
care
blocked really you came to me
i tell you i don't want to have anything
to do so you don't have to worry about
me going to you
you block me i don't care about the
blocking but it just tells me
what your mindset and your mind frame is
but yet the
thing the gift card you you know you
know yo i go
i go i go that's that's what that
that that's what i get when i get to
bars and the girls try to do whatever
and i'm like yeah and i'm good
i go go they fling it out oh it's cause
you
first they come in saying oh i'm a fan
of what you do and then
when i flip it up if when i'm flipping
on them they're like oh yeah whatever i
knew you was
anyways with your ass that's the norm
that's my norm
that's my norm where i refuse i refuse
my
the card real quick oh you this you that
blah blah it's because you
pretty ass [ __ ] or the dm if you don't
respond
they kept they keep on going it's like
60 40. when i say i don't i'm not
interested or whatever or they find out
i got a wife
they oh i apologize and that 40 is like
it's cool it's pristine
oh okay no uh my bad whatever if i just
say no
if i go and engage and i just say no why
i'm not that attracted to you
and i got a wife so even if i didn't
have a wife you wouldn't be the thing
that i would go for i mean you asked for
you asked why no was not enough god damn
then the barrage the barrage of things
so this is just
usual this is monday morning is it
oh yeah right i'm okay cool
normal and they resort to that all the
time it's been like that since high
school it's like
because you're doing the right thing i
was raised right and my parents
told me not to take advantage of of
people when i was in high school and i
was not engaging with nobody
or i could have girlfriends and not try
anything that's my lane
you didn't fight you didn't invite me
nowhere you didn't this and that
whatever what not
i'm not gonna take advantage of you
because you're not used to that and the
people around you were toxic
that's your definition of what
masculinity is that's our success but
it's not that so
right right off the bat and even man
even
man wait wait a minute you're fighting
for people not to call you
but then i say no to you you call me you
know what you anyways you know you want
it
i'm like [ __ ] how are you using that
against me
it's crazy and i think i think with
ladies when they do it they don't a lot
of them are just not used to rejection
you know what i mean they're not because
they're usually getting they're getting
their way when they approach somebody
so when you say no does not compute
some of them lose these i've had that
happen so many times
girl hit me up and she's like um hey
let's talk and i'm like
sorry i'm really not trying to build you
know relationships or friendships with
strangers like it's not
i'm not interested she's like why not
because i don't know you said well you
can get to know me i'm like
but i'm not interested in getting to
know you well you're a toxic
and you're a yes person unsubscribed yes
i'm like
where did this come from all i said was
no gently
you kept pushing and i just said i'm not
interested i didn't say anything rude i
didn't call you any names
i'm not interested bruh if i reacted
that way to every girl who said no to me
bro
i'll be in jail yeah absolutely it's
crazy that women have to deal with that
but yo
men also have to deal with that there's
a video it's just a video where a guy
goes around i remember what his name is
and he asked women can men refuse
but it's just astonishing and i know
there's montage and everything and stuff
but i know a lot of people think like
that yeah a lot of people that
a lot of people that claim that they're
a womanist a lot of people that don't
want equality and stuff like that but
when it comes to that it's like no
what huh they don't they don't recognize
it they don't compute and they don't
even compute
what it is people that i know that i
know
that they call themselves big time f
womanist
they oh they are on the forefront of
this thing
and but i i know that they've been
having some toxic
way of dealing with people saying no to
them and they're like
what you this and that how could because
they're not used to it
how do you deal with it i just blocked
it
if you're gonna be toxic i'm just gonna
block you it's not complicated yeah
i don't need that in my life deuces was
it
who raised you why would you talk to
somebody like that i just let it go i'm
so you i'm used to that it's been
it's been my life i'm like yeah sure
whatever welcome that's it move on your
day
i have to see people again yeah
black feature is great so it's not bad
it's just it's astonishing for me that
i didn't want to have anything to do
with you yeah and you blocked me like
i'm about to go back i don't care
no but they i know why but go ahead why
they
why are they blocking me first for
control
go on that's what it all comes down to
so you had to control the situation by
being able to say no
yeah they wanted to take back that
control yeah so they said i'm blocking
you
yeah before you block me it's crazy
that's what it is
[Music]
oh